bonjour merci d'être notre invité
politique si vous êtes le maire de
chalon sur saône vice présidents des
républiques en détention pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par fabrice
veysseyre redon bojan fabrice bonjour
original bonjour suite l'ajout du groupe
ebra vos journaux régionaux gilles
platret on commence évidemment par ce
qui s'est passé hier réd merdes qui
s'est donc terminée après trois jours de
congrès c'était manuel macron qui a
conclu ce congrès une heure de discours
est ce qui vous a séduit le chef de
l'état hier dans son discours je suis si
désolée je ne sais pas céder à son
pouvoir légendaire de séduction non il a
il a été très offensif faut quand même
reconnaître cette réalité parce que la
meilleure défense ça reste l' attaque et
que la résolution qui a été lu et adopté
à l'unanimité du bureau juste le
rappeler parce que vous savez qu'il a
ciblé andré laignel comme le lecteur le
message de cette résolution
cette résolution a donc été adopté à
l'unanimité du bureau ça veut dire y
compris par les membres de la liste
philippe laurent qui comme chacun sait
avait été largement téléguidé depuis
l'elysée donc bien sûr c'est important
qu'on va revenir sur le fond de discours
bien sûr andré laignel qui est le vice
président 2 mais ce qui est
effectivement été attaqué par le chef de
l'état qui a aussi été attaqués durant
cette campagne pour la présidence de
l'association il ya un problème andré
laignel non il n'y a aucun problème
andré laignel je pense que le président
la république dans son jeu essaye de
faire croire qu'il ya un problème en
fait il a essayé de diviser aujourd'hui
air life c'était très clair la stratégie
c'était ciblé quelques-uns on a bien vu
qu'il ya eu un tacle pour françois
baroin à d'ailleurs mais on a surtout vu
effectivement qui avait une attaque
contre andré laignel ces deux sessions
par an autant concerne l'ancien
maire de troyes et c'est quand il a faim
on a senti tout ça et je pense que le
l'erreur serait de dire finalement le
président jette le projecteur sur une
division qui n'existe pas je le dis bien
l'acte fondateur d'une décision
politique c'est le vote or la résolution
qui donne résolution dure que la mf a
produite à la veille du discours
présidentiel
même le matin même puisqu'elle a été
adoptée lorsque le bureau s'est reformé
est une résolution qui a été adoptée par
tout le monde donc il n'ya pas de
division à la mf sauf celle que le
président république et cei
pourquoi et parce que son jeu mais pour
la même raison qu'il a téléguidé une
liste c'est à dire essayer de casser
l'unité de la mf puisque c'est pour lui
à ses yeux un contre-pouvoir et qu'il
n'aime pas comme chacun sait les
contre-pouvoirs et qu'il a peur que
demain ce soit hélas pour lui je dis
bien pour lui une gêne dans sa campagne
présidentielle on a vu un président en
campagne hier n'y a pas besoin de se
raconter d'histoires il est très
clairement en campagne donc la mf unis
le jem vous avez vu une attaque contre
la gauche rappelant qu'andré l'aîné
avait quand même représentante de la
gauche historique dans le fonctionnement
de la mf vous avez vu une attaque contre
les socialistes n'ont de las palmas je
dirais pas ça je pense qu'il ya eu une
volonté de faire croire que la
résolution dure exigeons voté par le
bureau était l'oeuvre d'un seul or cette
résolution si elle a été élue par andré
laignel a été adopté par tout le monde à
l'issue de débats on ne peut plus
démocratique donc le jeu c'était de dire
mais regardez finalement cette marotte
anti gouvernement ou état c'est le fait
d' andré laignel pas non c'est pas le
fait d' andré laignel même s'il y a mis
la saveur qu'on lui connaît dans la
lecture il n'a fait que lire un texte
approuvé par chacun le chef de l'état
qui a commencé son discours en parlant
malentendu début de son quinquennat
avoir de préjugés vous l'appeliez vous à
tirer les leçons de ce quinquennat dans
sa relation entre lui et les élus locaux
est ce que pour vous après son discours
vous dites il a tiré la leçon non non
non il n'a pas tiré la leçon n'a pas vu
d'amande honorât vous savez c'est une
petite phrase moi j'ai vu je vous le
disais en introduction un président très
offensif parce que il n'est pas allé sur
les sujets qui fâchent on pourrait il
nous a dit finalement que tout allait
bien et que nous n'avions aucune aucun
motif de nous plaindre tout va bien les
dotations augmente les formalités
administratives diminue donc finalement
tout va pour le mieux dans le meilleur
des mondes c'était étonnant c'est tout
de même parce que les mères ressentent
et donc moi j'ai pas vu un président
séducteur j'ai vu un président qui
essaye de parler au delà des mers à une
opinion publique en disant mais
finalement c'est passé c'est la méthode
coué ou c'est le saint le président
déconner
je ne dirais pas je ne dirais pas ça je
pense qu'il est parfaitement connecté
sur les réalités simplement c'est un
président en campagne donc il a un
discours de campagne hier c'était un
président qui battait l'estrade devant
les maires mais pour parler au delà des
mers donc si sans mauvais jeu de mots
ultramarins mais ça veut dire
concrètement que il est pas dans
l'analyse des faits il est déjà dans le
reee pauline âge son mandat en disant
j'ai bien agi j'ai agi conformément à ce
que j'ai dit et donc vous avez tort de
vous plaindre c'est moi qui ai raison
donc c'est un président vraiment en
campagne sur internet est aussi un
président qui dénonce ouvrit mais un
débat mortifère entre t-il dit entre
l'état et les communes les collectivités
locales y'a pas un fond de vérité quand
même là dedans pas mais que le président
rappelle que nous sommes partie prenante
de l'organisation institutionnelle
française c'est une évidence nous sommes
représentant de la république dans un
service sur 2,1 g mortifère non mais ça
ça c'est le mot de trop parce que ça
veut dire que finalement nous serions un
seul bloc et que nous n'aurions plus
aucune occasion de critiquer la
politique du gouvernement et du
président on voit bien la manoeuvre la
manoeuvre c'est de dire taisez vous
silence dans les rangs c'est moi le chef
sauf que il n'est pas le chef des mères
il est le président de république civil
donne une force institutionnel
incontestable mais il ne peut pas dans
l'exercice de son mandat
méprise et non pas simplement les maires
notre personne n'a aucun intérêt mais
les communes c'est-à-dire l'institution
qui est la plupart des besoins des
habitants ce que nous réclamons au fond
dans la résolution est dans le travail
qui va être menée avant l'élection
présidentielle puisque nous allons
produire des propositions soumises aux
candidats et donc comme il est certain
que monsieur macron sera candidat à sa
succession il l'aura également à
discuter des propositions que nous le
soumettrons c'est tout simplement de
nous donner les moyens d'agir pour que
les besoins de la population soit
satisfait c'est quand même
extraordinaire que nous devions mendier
des pouvoirs pour être juste près nos
concitoyens et répondre à leurs besoins
c'est ce que nous demandons avec force
au président durant la campagne
précédente il était déjà venu devant
vous puisque la csc ça s'est très mal
passé oui mais avec jamais cet exercice
bien sûr écouter les candidats avant la
campagne et c'est un peu ce qu'il a dit
hier il a dit moi quand je suis venue
devant vous en 2016 je vous ai dit qu'il
n'y aurait pas de baisses de dotations
il n'y a pas eu de baisse de notation je
vous ai dit que je voulais supprimer la
taxe d'habitation j'ai supprimé la taxe
d'habitation est ce que finalement
aujourd'hui vous pouvez lui reprocher ça
il n'a fait que faire ce qu'il a dit il
ya eu un exercice hier de
reconsidération de relecture de son
propre passage c'était dans grand
auditorium de radio france j étais je
m'en souviens très bien où l'accueil
avait été non pas frais mais hostile il
avait comme il en a eu quelques-uns hier
même si les a faits traiteur terre très
vite des sifflets l'avait accueilli dans
ses propositions donc nous dire qu'il
n'a pas baisser les dotations d'abord
c'est une inexactitude pour un grand
nombre de communes je vais vous donner
un exemple
effectivement monsieur hollande avait
comme vous le savez drastiquement baissé
nos dotations les dotations qui sont pas
simplement un cadeau que l'état est aux
communes mais une compensation des
compétences que l'état a délégué aux
communes et bien donc nous fonctionnons
depuis 2015 avec des dotations en moins
qui nous sont dus donc on peut
s'attendre tout de même à ce qu un
président qui aime la justice c'est ce
qui nous dit lui-même rétablisse un
niveau pour que nous permettre d'exercer
nos compétences ça n'a pas été le cas et
de surcroît et c'est là où le diable est
dans le détail évidemment dans un grand
discours de d'apologie personnel il n'en
parlera jamais c'est que des compétences
nouvelles qui ont été transférées
subrepticement je pense par exemple pour
les communes importantes qui gère
maintenant la totalité d'instruction des
cartes d'identité et des passeports par
leur donnez moi d'être trivial mais
c'est notre quotidien eh bien ça n'a pas
été compensées à l'euro donc en fait
nous avons payé davantage on a parlé la
crise sanitaire il nous a fait en parler
fable sur le fait que l'état aurait
remboursé tous que les communes ont
avancé mais c'est une erreur
fondamentale moi je peux je peux le
prouver par défi dans ma commune comme
les autres maires les centres de
vaccination les moyens matériels et
moyens humains que nous avons mis et et
de bon coeur en place mais c'est ce sont
des frais que les ars ne rembourseront
pas complètement donc on voit bien que
quand on rentre dans le détail ce beau
discours finalement vous n'avez rien
perdu est une erreur c'est même un
mensonge pardonnez moi je le dis avec le
respect de la fonction mais je le dis
bien nous sommes face à un président en
campagne qui ne s'embarrasse pas des
détails et qui a juste un message à
faire passer j'aurais tenu tous les
engagements que j'ai pris la vérité
c'est que les communes sont plus à loos
à la fin de ce mandat qu'elle ne l'était
au début et ça c'est la réalité que nous
vivons quotidiennement la faute au
président de la république à l'état ou
une crise sanitaire justement qui a
compliqué aussi les budgets des communes
alors c'est certain mais vous savez f1
la crise sanitaire
est ce qu'elle est une affaire locale ou
est ce qu'elle est une affaire nationale
elle est tout à fait en herbe
internationale sur le plan médical mais
elle est une affaire nationale sur le
plan de la solidarité donc ça n'est pas
aux communes même si nous l'avons fait
parce qu'on n'a pas discuté une seule
seconde quand on a commencé de mettre
tout en place quand on a distribué des
masques aux hôpitaux parce que l'état
était incapable de le faire vous croyez
qu'on a demandé avant si on allait être
remboursés est sûr que l'on y avait une
urgence on a agi quand on a mis en place
des centres de vaccination on n'a pas
demandé un chèque à l'état avant de les
mettre en place donc on l'a fait
naturellement parce qu'on répond
naturellement aux besoins de la
population mais le jeu de dupes c'est
qu'aujourd'hui l'état ne rembourse pas
alors que c'est complètement dans sa
mission complètement dans sa mission ne
rembourse pas aux communes l'équivalent
des dépenses qu'elles ont consentis je
vais même aller plus loin nous sommes un
certain nombre de communes à être allé
au delà l'accompagnement au soutien du
pouvoir d'achat moi j'ai fait des
opérations de distribution de bons
d'achat à tous les agents du service
public ou du service privé qui avait été
impliqué dans la gestion du premier
confinement ça évidemment ça sera jamais
remboursée mais je ne demande pas le
remboursement là-dessus ce que je veux
simplement vous dire c'est que nous
sommes allés au delà donc si on
la ville de chalon chara millions 5,1
millions 5 voilà et je vais régulant
qu'aujourd'hui dont une partie non on
aura remboursement d'une partie mais
jeudi bien que d'anciens mis enceinte je
suis très à daegu il ya des dépenses qui
ne seront pas pour sable c'est celle que
nous avons décidé de nous mêmes
notamment pour maintenir et soutenir le
pouvoir d'achat c'est des exonérations
de taxe sur la publicité extérieure des
droits de place etc mais ça nous ne
demandons pas le remboursement l'état
nous demandons simplement que l'état
déjà nous rembourse ce qui dépend de lui
c'est à dire nous avons été le bras armé
de sa politique sanitaire sur la gestion
des masques sur la gestion des centres
de vaccination qu'au moins là dessus il
rembourse aux communes ce qu'elles ont
avancé au nom de l'état est là pour le
moment le compte n'y est pas on va
reparler de la crise sanitaire et de la
lutte contre la 5e balle mais pour
continuer sur ce qu'a dit le chef de
l'état hier il a parlé de sécurité qui
est évidemment un sujet qui préoccupe
les français qui s occupent les maires
et là il dit non mais c'est pas vrai
l'état ne se désengage pas du tout en
matière de sécurité qu'est ce que vous
dites est ce à moi je pense qu'il ya
aujourd'hui alors je serais plus modérée
dans la critique que je peux opposés au
président république sur le sujet on a
manifestement une volonté de l'état
d'être plus présents sur le terrain mais
tout ça vient avec après des épisodes et
une aggravation de la violence dans la
société elle même donc ça ne doit pas
être perçu comme une faveur que l'état
consente irait aux communes c'est
simplement les moyens qu'il se donne
pour assurer la sécurité de nos
concitoyens j'ajouterai simplement une
chose
vous savez l'effort énorme que les
communes consentent elle même pour la
sécurité de leurs concitoyens
aujourd'hui les polices municipales
s'appuie et c'est bien normal largement
sur les réseaux de vidéoprotection qui
les a payés les comédies elles ont été
un peu aidées par l'état c'est vrai mais
pas complètement donc on a ici une arme
qui est une arme vraiment pour régler
les affaires pour prévenir qui est
largement payés par les collectivités
territoriales et en particulier les
communes donc on voit bien que c'est une
compétence partagée l'état assure sa
part nous avons souvent dit que bien sûr
il fallait de la présence policière mais
attention la présence policière n'est
rien si les moyens matériels ne change
pas que vous ayez des policiers sur le
terrain mais qui n'est pas les pistolets
à impulsion électrique nécessaire les
voitures de service pour aller dans les
quartiers un peu chaud ça ne servira à
rien donc on voit bien que ne nous
laissons pas à simplement parce que
monsieur darmanin est très fort là
dessus abusée par la politique du
chiffre il faut aussi la bdic de la
qualité donc il faut les deux et on
essaie que les chiffres en terme
d'augmentation
je reconnais là ça complètement mais je
reconnais aussi que parallèlement les
chiffres augmentent en matière d'
attaques sur les biens et les personnes
et ça c'est quand même inquiétant c'est
à dire que prix sur les nuls est ce que
vous même vous êtes assez j'ai été
menacée je ne sais pas s'il ya un élu
qui ne l'a jamais été oui disent qu'il
est protégé aujourd'hui par l'êta gérald
darmanin annoncé de nouvelles mesures
pour renforcer la sécurité des élus la
semaine dernière est ce que ce sont les
bonnes mesures et léger est à mes côtés
sur ce j'ai pu tester auprès d'un
collègue mr d'ailleurs que les choses
sont allées très vite c'est un incident
qui s'est passé dans sa commune il ya
une dizaine de jours et en une semaine
la sphère été réglé je trouve que c'est
plutôt bien c'était une menace avec un
voies de fait sur sur un maire et la
personne concernée a été condamné à des
dommages-intérêts interdiction de le
rencontrer pendant plus d'un an en moins
d'une semaine donc ça fonctionne bien
simplement disons bien les choses moi je
suis pas là pour faire du corporatisme
que c'est rapidité qu'on est capable
justice et gendarmerie ou police de
faire respecter pour les élus qu'on la
fasse aussi pour les citoyens parce que
si demain la le moindre la moindre
insulte un maire est condamné en une
semaine et que vous avez des concitoyens
qui sont menacés parfois agressés et qui
voient leur plein de traîner pendant des
années ça ne marchera pas donc pas trop
de corporatisme de la protection nous
portons une partie de l'autorité nous
devons être protégé en tant que tel mais
attention ce n'est pas à nous de passer
avant le reste de la population un
dernier mot sur congrès des maires après
on va parler de crise sanitaire avec sa
voix est ce que c'est aussi le congrès
du renouvellement david rozehnal que
vous souteniez a donc été élu président
de l'association des maires de france il
succède à françois baroin vous nous
parler du bureau hier comment il s'est
passé ce premier bureau et quelle place
va avoir philippe laurent le concurrent
de david lisnard dans les instances de
la m vous savez que je siège était tête
de liste pour le comité directeur donc
mais je sais quand même ce qui s'est un
peu passé hier matin on a eu d'ailleurs
une quelques allusions pendant les
discours des personnalités qui sont
montés au créneau pour défendre leurs
idées et puis je pense que en tout cas
c'est la lecture que nous avons en fait
l'institution elle même la rfa a repris
toute sa place c'est-à-dire nous
travaillons dans le consensus c'est
toujours la base droite gauche centre
réunis pour en voir une seule voie et
vous voyez que en fait c'est ce que je
vous disais en introduction la
résolution finale qui a été lu par andré
laignel a été adoptée on a bien montré
masque philippe laurent
c'est à lui de nous le dire j'ai cru
comprendre que sur votre plateau s'il
veut la garde j'ai cru comprendre sur
votre plateau il avait lui-même émis ce
qui n'apparaissait pas comme un souhait
absolu de la garder je ne fêterai il
aime raconter en disant qu'il voulait
travailler mais ça je pense parce que
enfin c'est une nécessité on a été
opposé le temps de la campagne est
terminée maintenant bon montrer un front
uni parce qu'il en va de l'avenir de la
commune et donc de l'avenir de nos
consciences vous voulez qu'il reste mais
moi je vous personnellement mais oui
majeur fin qui dresse à sa fonction
précédente ou à une autre mais qu'il
soit là avec tous ceux qui ont été élus
avec lui on a besoin de retrouver le
chemin d'unités mais l'unité ça se
travaille des deux côtés
oui vous parlez de la vaccination gilles
platret ya quelques instants plusieurs
pays européens dont l'allemagne
l'autriche prennent des mesures
notamment de confinement pour les non
vaccinés vous pensez que c'est une
mesure qui serait applicable en france
elle serait détestable je vous donne mon
sentiment
allez à ce point de division de la
société française en condamnant en
assignant à résidence les seuls non
vaccinés ne me paraît hors de tout état
de droit on peut pas faire une
différence à ce point entre les
concitoyens qu'il faille se protéger
c'est une évidence absolue et dieu sait
si nora blond sans cesse les consignes
mais divisé la population sur cette base
là non je vous donne mon avis c'est non
à mon sens et je note d'ailleurs que
notamment en autriche
les choses sont en train de changer
cette division de la société a été
contestée y compris d'ailleurs par les
forces de l'ordre qui devait la faire
respecter et aujourd'hui le gouvernement
est en train de être aux pédales et donc
je pense que le gouvernement français
regarde aussi ce qui se passe de l'autre
côté de nos frontières et même un peu
plus loin s'agissant de l'autriche et
j'espère qu'on ne tombera pas dans cet
excès oui à la protection la population
non à la division du peuple français on
est en campagne pré campagne
présidentielle oui on pourrait on peut
le dire oui on peut le dire est ce que
ça va être compliqué de mener des
politiques une politique sanitaire
prévention même dans cette période sans
prendre le risque d'être impopulaire
c'est compliqué évidemment mais il
faudrait pas que ça soit aussi un outil
dans la main du président la dernière
intervention présidentielle télévisée
vous l'avez suivi comme moi je me suis
demandé à la fin pourquoi il avait pris
la parole sinon peut-être pour rappeler
les consignes mais surtout de mettre un
coup de pression vous savez que la peur
est un moyen de gouvernement
je souhaite simplement que le présent
république avec les responsabilités
particulières qui sont les siennes ne
joue pas sur ce sentiment de peur pour
anesthésier le débat présidentiel
je pense que la tentation existe voilà
et j'ai un peu lui sa dernière
intervention à cette lumière là je ne
dis pas et je ne dirai jamais qu'il ne
faut pas se protéger je pense qu'il est
impératif que chacun adopte vis-à-vis
des autres les gestes qui les protège
qui nous protège que les teams ans donc
ce n'est pas l'idée de baisser la garde
simplement nous tombons moins de l'excès
inverse c'est à dire ne faisons pas de
la peur un moyen de campagnes
électorales en tout cas on y sera très
attentif aux républicains comme ailleurs
un mot sur le budget une décision des
sénateurs les républicains le sénat est
à majorité de droite on le rappelle
qu'ils ont rejetée l'indemnité
l'inflation 200 euros promise par jean
castex pour l'aimer pour les personnes
gagnant moins de 2000 euros net par mois
vous soutenez sur le choix des sénateurs
je pense que l'idée ait des sénateurs
s'étaient pas de priver de pouvoir
d'achat nos concitoyens c'était
simplement de mettre un coup d'arrêt à
une démagogie préélectorale on va être
très clair depuis la crise et gilet
jaune c'est open bar surtout les
soutiens le quoi qu'il en coûte qui
aujourd'hui est devenu une règle de
gouvernement budgétaire alors que il ya
quelques mois on aurait sauté au plafond
en parlant de cela le quoi qu'il en
coûte ne peut pas être une règle de
campagne électorale nous aurons et vous
l'avez bien notées notamment dans les
débats de nos candidats nous avons
encore un grand débat demain devant le
conseil national des républicains nous
aurons des mesures en faveur du pouvoir
d'achat mais dites vous bien une chose
c'est que la philosophie politique qui
est la nôtre c'est pas de donner
systématiquement d'échecs avec l'argent
des autres puisque l'état n'est pas sa
propre banque l'argent qu'il donne est
forcément celui du contribuable ou celui
des générations futures s'ils
s'endettent c'est d'abord de réduire les
charges et les impôts ça c'est une
logique qui est la nôtre on voit bien
que monsieur macron et dans la
distribution des cadeaux pré noël et
surtout pré électoraux et je pense que
les sénateurs ont simplement voulu mener
c'est non pas leur soutien au peuple
français parce qu'on a quand même
beaucoup de mesures qui ont été
proposées ils ont restreint la cible
c'est à dire qu'il
ya moins de français
vous avez bien vu informelle en touche
en plus on a dit que la prime inflation
devait d'abord c'était la philosophie
aider ceux qui subissent l augmentation
notamment du prix des carburants et des
consommables or d'une manière
électoraliste au possible la cible a été
étendu à tout le monde et c'est ça que
les sénateurs conteste et ils ont raison
qu'on est ce qu'ils subissent mais qu'on
ne donne pas des bons d'achat à
quiconque qui sont en fait des bulletins
de vote déguisé allez on va parler des
débats puisque vous le disais
effectivement il ya un grand débat
demain devant le le conseil national
puis dimanche troisième débat des
républicains
vous dites je suis porte parole je ne
peux pas me prononcer il ya quand même
un candidat qui va préfèrons son
l'imaginons mais je resterai je suis
désolé de ne pas satisfaire à votre
demande vous savez pourquoi pour une
simple et bonne raison
christian jacob président du parti les
deux porte-paroles année c'est vrai mais
moi avons décidé de rester dans la
neutralité pour une simple et bonne
raison c'est que nous portons tous les
trois la voix du parti vous avez des
membres du bureau des membres de
l'équipe dirigeante qui ont pris parti
pour les uns et pour les autres et c'est
bien légitime mais quand vous venez
comme je le fais ce matin sur un plateau
télévision je remercie encore votre
habitation vous ne pouvez pas au nom du
parti parce que je porte aussi dire je
préfère un tel nous ce qui nous importe
par contre je peux vous dire la
philosophie qui peut nous anime et on
voit bien que on sent que dans ces
débats les choses avancent et que
notamment des thèmes qui pouvait être un
peu tabou à une époque sont en train de
revenir sur le des biens d'ailleurs ces
critiques énormément par la gauche j'ai
entendu monsieur jadot qui nous
refaisait la devise de la république
puisqu'il nous accuse pratiquement des
thèses d'extrême droite maintenant je
sens simplement que la parole est en
train de se libérer chez les
républicains sur
free de se libérer de se droitiser elle
se libère pour une simple et bonne
raison c'est que je le crée l'air pour
le coup je peux le dire même si je
ferait grincer quelques dents dans ma
famille politique je pense que nous
avons trop subi les oukases idéologique
de la gauche ces dernières années nous
n'avons pas osé mettre des mots sur des
réalités que pourtant nous voyons comme
spectateurs ou acteurs locaux sur le
terrain aujourd'hui cette parole est en
train de se libérer c'est à dire mais on
s'est libéré grâce à eric zemmour est-ce
que c'est lui qui a permis aux
républicains de dire certaines choses
qu'il n'avait pas dix jours répond cash
je pense qu'il y avait des voix là je
vais pas vous raconter d'histoires je
pense que finalement il pose une
question à tout le monde je vous parle
pas des réponses qu'ils apportent qu'il
apporte pas encore je parle du constat
et je crois c'est pas le seul parce
qu'on sent bien que les choses avancent
dans notre famille politique depuis un
petit moment j'ai peut-être été un peu
précurseur on me l'a reproché à
certaines occasions aujourd'hui dans la
campagne des régionales oui nos
décisions locales par rapport aux
cantines etc notamment en 2015 sur la
question des cantines et du respect de
la laïcité donc simplement ce que je
sens et moi c'est pour le coup c'est une
vraie demande a beaucoup je ne prends
pas parti mais je dis simplement que si
nous ratons ce coche si les républicains
ne met pas des mots sur des réalités qui
sont tangibles visible par nos
concitoyens alors ils passeront à côté
de cette élection et nous savons ce qui
se passerait si jamais nous ne sommes
pas au deuxième tour d'élections on va
avoir beaucoup de difficulté à passer ce
cap présidentielle et notamment la
survie du parti ce pourrait être engagée
donc on a un besoin de franchise et de
vérité si zemmour nous y aider tant
mieux je pense que la réalité nous le
commande en tout cas eric zemmour vous
disiez vous répandez cache le concernant
c'est un candidat de droite pour vous je
n'ai pas senti fondamentalement
socialistes 159
moi je pense pas qu'il soit d'extrême
droite voilà alors vous savez que ça
pour le coup c'est un débat au sein des
républicains soyons clairs là dessus je
n'exprime pas la ligne du parti
politique je vous donne un avis
personnel pour moi il a une lecture de
droite de ce qui se passe sur le terrain
maintenant je le dit j'attends les
solutions je vous savez que le point
faible eric zemmour son point fort c'est
de faire un constat qui est largement
partagé par une partie de l'opinion
publique y compris d'ailleurs des
électeurs de droite soyons clairs mais
en revanche on attend maintenant les
solutions parce que là aussi le diable
est dans le détail si eric zemmour qui
est très bon sur le constat est mauvais
sur les solutions je pense que la force
ne passera pas noël soyons très clairs
là dessus aussi sur les solutions que ça
vous a pas échappé mais pour ça faut
déjà que con ça serait partagée eric
zemmour qui n'est toujours pas candidat
mais qui envisagent de se déclarer au
moment de votre congrès quand vous le
prendre écoutez cette bonne guerre si
tenté qu'il est de bonne guerre chacun
mène sa barque c'est pas moi de 2,2
d'estimer si l'agenda de monsieur
zemmour est le bon on avait annoncé un
première déclaration de candidature le 9
novembre jour emblématique du gaullisme
ça a été reporté écoutez ça c'est son
jeu c'est pas le voter quelqu'un vous
pourriez rejoindre
la question on a quand même l'impression
que vous ne ménagez un petit peu alors
mais je ne ménage rien du tout moi je
fais partie de ceux qui partagent un
certain nombre de constats avec lui je
vais pas vous raconter d'histoires je
suis pas venu là pour casser eric
zemmour parce que ce qu'il dirait la
lecture de son actualité ou de la vérité
qu'il a sous les yeux est la même que la
mienne mais si on fait un candidat est
chaud vous soutiendrez candidats et
attendait
mais notre candidat a vocation à réussir
si on commence à se mettre dans cette
idée est que nous partons perdons mais
alors c'est même pas la peine de partir
merci beaucoup
[Musique]